huge explosion in the capital of Yemen
saana after us air strike This Is War
ladies and gentlemen so uh yeah I don't
I don't think we're getting we're
getting any sound out of this but there
is sound yeah sound's not coming through
guys but uh we we'll come back to that
later I'm not super concerned about
people hearing popping noises but this
is the big breaking story we got ABC
News us UK launch large scale
retaliatory strikes against Iran backed
hoodi militants in Yemen the hoodies had
made repeated attacks on the Red Sea
shipping despite us warnings now we have
this story from the conversation why
Yemen's hoodies are getting involved in
the Israel Hamas war and how it could
disrupt global Shipping basically they
there's there's a video I mean have you
guys seen this video where the
helicopter like lands and seizes the
shipping vessel this is nuts we had Eric
Prince on the culture war and he just
outright mentioned I mean this could
shut down a majority of global Shipping
by controlling this route the end result
is fairly obvious massive escalation of
war in the region Iran of course has to
retaliate in some way so far they've
been having their uh militias attack us
bases but this is a component of the
Israel war in Gaza and it's I got to
tell you it's actually really sad to see
because I remember when we got the
breaking news about the Abraham Accords
during the Trump Administration and how
you get all these these liberals and and
Democrats these personalities were
claiming that it was nothing that it was
just paying off people whatever it's not
real peace and my attitude was dude you
have flights traveling over Muslim
nations to Israel from Muslim nations to
Israel we are actually moving forward
with the basic components of
longstanding business was being
conducted you because they probably
always wanted to uh you know a lot of
reasons why they couldn't but they they
they changed that and now uh watching
the region fall apart so quickly the
capitulation to Iran and the
you it's just insane man like you know
the the adults were supposed to be back
in charge and
I'm knew there's so you knew I mean of
course you knew you knew with the Afghan
withdrawal right you know they didn't
really want to learn how to win a war
but they wanted to learn about white
rage and uh you know the the worst I
think for me for that one I think we
discussed it last time I was on the show
was just watching you know the the
Secretary of State get up there you know
before Congress uh and do his thing uh
that he was and I quote shocked and
dismayed that the Taliban did not
install a more diverse and inclusive
government but no I mean I was like I
literally like I was like you're joking
right like but but they weren't like
that was like you know the Taliban that
you've been fighting in a war for 20
years that throw homosexuals off
buildings like you thought they were
going to have like you know a trans
Coalition in Islam you wait like come on
well to be Fair perhaps he thought when
China moved in and took over the region
that may be a path they move but no
that's actually unfair because China has
masculinity training for their for their
young people and they put out
commercials or or propaganda to get
their young men ripped and Ready for War
they're women too I watched a video of
kids this is how they're training the
kids in schools as they'll each have two
basketballs that they're bouncing and
then they jump to the right and they
have the next basketball so there's all
these 24 basketballs in a circle and
like 12 kids or there's a lot more than
that actually hey but our kids know that
there's
4762 genders so like we got that going
for us and and that does doesn't even
include the the Chinese super soldier
program um that they also enacted and
are actively genetically gene splicing
individuals in order to become the next
Super Soldier so there's that but this
situation happening in Yemen is is a
pretty big deal it's the United States
it's the United Kingdom they just bombed
the capital of Yemen with support of
Qatar and Saudi Arabia there's a lot of
history here because this is the
continuation of a previous campaign
where the United States and the Saudi
Arabians were essentially working with
al- Qaeda and a lot of Sunni Rebels
trying to get after specifically these
houti Rebels that are tied into Iran so
there's a lot of history here there's a
lot of DEC ations here there's a lot of
trade on the line there's a lot of
things at stake here that that really
are important to bring up during this
matter as of course this conflict could
expand very easily to Iran and if that
happens it's just going to be
devastating I need to bring up a quick
Point um I think it was like two years
ago Luke made a comment on this show
that Bill Gates was developing
microchips that could uh uh give be
birth function as birth control and I
just started laughing I was like Luke
get out it is not true and then I
Googled it and yeah it's actually yeah
it's implantable chip that can be
activated by an app that would turn on
and turn off birth control so for
everybody who heard Luke just say that
China is creating genetically engineered
super solders Jean sping technology
sping technology I know there are people
watching being like okay this guy's
crazy from the guardian three years ago
China conducting biological tests to
create super soldiers us spy Chief says
intelligence director John Ratcliff
claims human testing aims to develop
Soldiers with biologically enhanced
capabilities okay fair point maybe the
guy was lying but is it even surprising
I mean you just you understand what like
they they're actually playing to win
like is anyone actually surprised that
they would be doing that like I'm not
even a little bit I'm actually surprised
this story is from three years ago not
from 23 years ago but this is what we
know about imagine the stuff that we
don't know about and to have another
Chinese connection here it was the
Chinese that brokered a larger peace
deal that first ended the war in Yemen
just a few months ago they they brought
Saudi Arabia and Iran to the table and
and said hey we're going to stop
fighting each other in in Yemen because
this was a larger proxy war I I think
right now the United States is
restarting this war with Saudi Arabia
not just because of the conflict not
just because of the interest of Israel
but specifically for us petrol dollar
hemony for Global hemony and to counter
the Chinese here in this very specific
region and and this is troubling because
the Chinese are using trade as an
initiative they're saying hey Saudi
Arabia Iran let's come to the table
let's let's let's get some energy out
there into the world stage the United
States is coming to this situation
saying hey uh we're just going to bomb
stuff here and we're bombing one of the
poorest countries in the world when I
think we could be utilizing a more
diplomatic a more kind of advantageous
policy that would be better for
America's interest and America's people
because right now with the open borders
the yemeni terrorists and and the rebels
how many Iranian sleeper cells are all
over the country right now they just
waiting to be activated it's not even
it's not even Iranian it's it's it's
Isis that the United States previously
supported it's al- Qaeda that the United
States also previously supported it's
it's a lot of fundamentalists it's a lot
of radicals that could just very easily
walk into the United States and wreck
havoc on our way of life very easily
with these stupid policies we have this
tweet from Mario nul statement from
democratic House member Valerie Howell
saying these air strikes on Yemen were
not authorized by Congress the
Constitution is clear that Congress is
the only Authority that allows military
intervention in foreign conflicts every
president must first come to Congress
and request military authorization
regardless of which party he belongs to
I'm really surprised the Democrat came
out and criticized unilateral military I
sort of feel like they've been really
fine with war in Eastern Europe and
sending you know billions of dollars and
then you have beyond the proxy war
whatever happened to that Tiera guy that
was leaking that we actually had boots
on the ground over there now he's
disappeared for six months we haven't
heard anything about that one uh well
maybe she's upset because it's not going
the missiles aren't being uh sent to
Ukraine perhaps I mean I'm surprised we
actually have missiles left given the
way they've depleted our stock piles
also a real problem uh especially given
what brought up as it relates to China
being adversarial and really sort of
encroaching on Taiwan and flying the
sorties over the top of there and you
know our allies are watching what's
going on around the world and we're sort
of an embarrassment I I wonder you know
it's I'm not I'm I'm 37 in two months
I'll be 38 I wonder were we just th
those around uh this age uh you know
like Luke and I are similar age were we
Lucky in growing up in a time where you
had these lesser conflicts that that
appeared you know all around of course
you had Iraq and Afghanistan but you did
not have
have basically every region on the verge
of imploding the way but but my point I
guess is before I was born of course I
was Vietnam there was the risk of
nuclear war with the Soviets so maybe
it's just a wakeup call for Millennials
yeah if you watch the borders change
over the last 2,000 years in Europe it's
constant constant Warfare taking over
countries and then World War II happened
Hitler and then all of a sudden it
stopped and it there was no more border
changes because of liberal economic
order we set up this global Military
Police then you see Bosnia break off of
Serbia and that was like the one thing
then the Soviet Union cracked apart and
it really diffused the tensions it so
you I was talking to Scott Harton about
this and you could argue that we're
actually in a state of deescalation but
just like but I don't know there's these
internal conflicts now and and the
things that you don't see on paper it it
feels I got to tell you when I look at
what's going on with the war and the
conf conflict and all this stuff as well
as what's going on with immigration
economics it feels intentional like it's
almost like Joe Biden the democ rats
know they're on the way out and if they
can't have it no one can and so they're
just I mean you look at Afghanistan how
is that anything but intentional you did
not have to abandon the BAM Air Force
Base in the middle of the night and not
tell the Afghan Security Forces I mean
line those things up let's say you
decided for some reason you had to
abandon bam okay well you tell the
security forces you don't do it in the
middle of the night you do it in
controlled matter let's say for some
reason you couldn't tell them you secure
the materials and the weapons and you
get rid of them before abandoning them
to the Taliban all all of those things
happening at once now you look at the
southern border with the Biden
Administration facilitating illegal
immigration it feels like he's this
Angry Kid the Democrats are playing ball
and they're like if I can't play with
the ball and they're going to they're
going to Chuck it over the fence so that
no one else can well it feels like a
child right because I literally I
remember when that was going on I picked
up my son Spencer he was like I think
nine at the time and I picked up up from
school as as the Afghan withdrawal was
going on and he's literally N9 years old
he's dad uh why why would we take out
the Army before like the people that
helped us you know I'm not going to be
that guy like you know my son was
questioning he's three and he was asking
about nuclear proliferation of the
Korean Peninsula you know the woke
that you see you know out there
you know with you know people sort of
virtue signaling but he was nine and he
was like why why would we leave 86
billion in equipment dad that's that's a
lot of equipment that like like a
9-year-old knew this you know and yet
you know the the adults back in charge
didn't so it has to be intentional you
know Southern border you could have just
maintained Trump's policy
but you know that way you can't you know
the great replacement Theory it's not a
theory I mean it's reality of course
they're doing this at this point right
now I think it's also fair to understand
that maybe what could have been
happening with uh Afghanistan is a
situation where you leave a lot of arms
and weapons to have the Taliban counter
Iran and Iraq in the region as well as
of course there was also a lot of
massive terrorist attacks that were just
committed inside of Iran by ISIS Rebels
Isis Rebels that also were armed by US
taxpayer dollarss and even had American
trucks with American businesses on the
side of them so when we look at the
situation in the Middle East I think it
all boils down to the military
industrial complex and the Intel
agencies and the powers that be coming
in there and just dropping a whole bunch
of weapons everywhere and then saying oh
there's bad guys picking up weapons that
we dropped that we paid for that we told
them to pick up against our geopolitical
foes that were going against the US
petrol dollar so there's a lot of
history here especially with the war in
Iraq that made Iran as powerful as they
are right now there's a lot of things
that happened specifically in Syria in
Libya that have created the current
talist situation right now and we need
to understand where a lot of these
people are coming from because the
hootsie rebels they are committing
terrorism they are blocking the trade
routs but they're also saying
specifically stop the war in Palestine
and then of course everything will will
calm down here and of course that war is
not going to be stopped the war in
Palestine I mean I remember when that I
first started seeing that you see the
imagery the pal you know the Hamas
soldiers were carrying m4s they weren't
carrying the traditional AK-47 lot of
the photos that I saw yeah that
according to the Intel reports they got
probably from Ukraine Ukraine or
Afghanistan where we left what was it
47,000 or significantly more uh so I
mean I guess you know instability in the
region works out great for the Deep
State and for the warmongers but no one
else take a look at this article from
Reuters Iran seizes oil tanker involved
in US Iran dispute in Gulf of Oman State
media and it's retaliation okay
so Iran seing an oil tanker this is this
is direct Iran is no longer just using
proxies to do this it is it is escalated
now to you know nation state level but
the United States has similar action
yeah this a tanker called the Suz Rajan
it's it's changed names because it used
to be a Greek oil tanker they were
delivering selling oil to the or
receiving oil from the Iranians with and
then the US went and took the tanker
from the Greeks and they were like it's
ours now and they sold all the oil the
Americans sold their oil for themselves
and then now this is they're taking the
the same tank or they're taking it back
um and
the because the the the Cassis belly
that the United States had to seize that
thing in the first place was you're
using American Financial systems to
transact so you're violating sanctions
on Iran it's now we're taking it I
remember when the world had a big
problem my father's like hey if we're
going to fix these countries why don't
we at least take some of the oil for
ourselves and pay ourselves back and
that was a big problem for for everyone
but apparently yeah well that's the
statement he said specifically with with
Syria and and essentially that's what
the United States did but there was also
a a very interesting news report I don't
know if you could confirm this or give
us more details about this specific with
Trump requesting a lot of military
personel to be removed from Syria and
then the generals kind of lied to him
about it um so so how how can we move
forward with a future Trump presidency
how is this going to be kind of handled
and approached from here when when
clearly there's there's a whole other
power structure here that's creating a
lot of the chaos well listen I think you
have to clean house uh at these places
right you saw it this week alone with
Lloyd Austin I mean he's the Secretary
of Defense he's out it's terrible that
he has cancer but you know we're as you
mentioned we're on the brink of three
now four perhaps different possible
fronts for you know escalated conflict
and he's out of pocket for 5 days you
know they they replaced him with a
lovely lady I'm sure who was on and she
was on vacation in Puerto Rico you know
that's wonderful but like you're the
acting Secretary of Defense while the
secretary of defense is in a hospital
the Biden Administration doesn't know
they didn't bother to tell him till this
week and like all is well folks like I
mean no no no but it but it there is a
component of it that's like just showing
you that this deep State this
military-industrial complex they don't
believe that they answer to the civilian
you know chain of command uh they're
above and beyond they know better they
haven't really done a great job of
winning wars in the last you know 50
years or so but like but they still know
better and they're going to do whatever
they want thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at Tim
cast.com for uncensored membersonly
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next
time